let me be clear my top priority is
public safety there's nothing more
important to me and that's what my
office does all day every day is we
fight for public safety you know the
city is a train wreck and it's been
getting progressively worse over time
i mean i i understand restorative
justice on some level but i mean you
know we still got to have some order too
you know obviously we're in a situation
where something needs to change with the
duties that people have the way in
neutral someone needs to actually do
something
you all just heard a lot of lies a lot
of dishonesty and a lot of spin and that
shouldn't be a surprise
because this is a recall we got a
problem over here let me see bang bang
bang you break something and wait a
minute they're out the next day yeah the
da's got to go that's how a lot of
people feel about it because they're not
he's not doing a job and everybody's
pissed off about it and this has been
going on too long so where's our
protection
a lot of
voters who voted for him actually felt
duped
felt like it was a patent switch
he never told the voters that he was
going to protect drug dealers he never
told anyone never told in in writing or
or verbally uh that he was going to
simply let virtually anyone that was
arrested with egregious crime out he
never said he was going to
um
that he was going to eliminate gang
enhancements he was not going to
charge any perpetrators with a gun
enhancement he was going to eliminate
that he never said any of that we are
now just ensuring that we're getting the
word out to everybody that there is a
recall election to remove chesapoli from
office and uh june 7th there are some
critics that say that removing chests of
bodine is not going to change anything
and i have i take exception with that we
haven't had an effective
prosecutorial office for more than two
years we're going to go on two and a
half years
him being removed being recalled out of
office will have an immediate effect
london breed our mayor is going to
replace him with what we hope to be a
good
a good prosecutor and that person is
going to rebuild the office with
prosecutors we are very easily able to
see
how many democrats
signed the petition how many green party
libertarian republican
and it's overwhelming
democrats why because san francisco is
overwhelmingly democrat chesapeau dean
has been trying to portray this
as a conservative or even republican
recall here in san francisco there are
so few republicans so
so to claim that it's republican or
conservative is is pretty much hogwash